what's up everyone we are back with John
cotton partner at the circling Institute
hey hey here we are again here we are
again we did a great 1 hour long vodcast
conversation which you guys can check
out it's in the channel as well as video
of John circling me so now I will be
circling John and circling is a process
of communication a very intimate
communication and diving deep peeling
back these layers so let's go ahead and
flip over where the sands of time
so John
that smile though how do you feel I feel
good being here with you yeah a little
tired just from the day life the last
few months and the last hour and a half
just kind of our intense focus yeah
it's the end of the day and I still feel
alive because there's a spark in your
eyes but what I gather from from you is
that you have a really important mission
and
the way that you communicated the vision
of your impact to me made me light up
and we actually didn't get to it in our
hour-long conversation so I think it'd
be good to mention now but your vision
of having this process of communicated
communication and intimacy be more
proliferated around the world especially
in areas of leadership like the United
Nations I think that is incredibly
important and it resonates with me
greatly it's a big vision it's a big
mission and your hustle must be very
difficult it's a lot it's a lot of work
to get there so I can only imagine there
is the heart has a lot of of other
feelings that come from not only the
business but other aspects of your life
your relationship your family and you I
know nothing about you basically so how
are those pieces of your life where to
start
I think right now I'm really in touch
with being driven by the passion of the
possibility of how this level of deep
relating and connecting and authenticity
and a willingness to really be with
someone in their world and get what it's
like to me the possibilities of if if
the world actually knew or most of the
people in the world knew how to
communicate this way it just seems like
it would be world-changing like like if
if it's grew up with this as like an
additional topic like learning how to
see and feel through somebody else's
eyes being able to share actually what's
truly going on and how they're being
affected being able to talk about what's
happening between people rather than you
know boys growing up just competing with
each other and I'm not sure how to
describe I don't have the right to
describe how girls grow up
I imagine like bullying would disappear
fighting would probably somewhat
disappear there'd be the tremendous
level of cooperation people I think kids
would be more in touch with what
inspires them and what they want to
learn versus like what they're having to
learn and regurgitation versus create
creativity just imagine a whole new
generation growing up with like really
bonded to each other and so like I have
a dream of just having this level of
communication weave back into the fabric
of society and the fabric of our lives
and so I want to see it in schools I
want to see it
in adult development trainings all over
the world as a possibility I want to see
I want to see it in corporations I think
corporations for most people think of it
as a really stagnant really hard place
to be because we have to shut down so
much of ourselves to be there like we
can't bring our true selves like what if
we could like what if there was a level
of care and love and compassion
that's like somehow that growth is like
part of the bottom line because it
contributes so much to the world and
it's whoever some genius is gonna figure
out how to incorporate it that into the
bottom line and and and calculated or
monetize it or something so then it's
it's seen for the value the true value
that it is and I think if we can get
this into government and and diplomacy
like you said United Nations like what
if every what if every international
interaction started with maybe a whole
day or two of like getting what it's
like to live in the other person's shoes
and fully getting their motivations and
their hurts and their struggles and
their
their desires and understanding it like
it's your own and then them and then
then knowing that they get that from you
too I think it would change the entire
conversations there would be a level of
care of like wanting to make it better
for you rather than just like how can we
win as much as we can possibly win
versus like how can we make it better
for all of us it's just I just think
there's so many applications of this
work that that are life-changing that
it's it's hard it's hard to take my
attention off of it it has to be so so
grabbed why
because it matters I think it it matters
to me the kind of world that I live in I
mean I started it I think the Y was just
personal that why your heart from from
here yeah what's the feeling of the Y
yeah I mean the because it's it feels
like love to me it's always been my
favorite thing to do more than anything
just to be with somebody like this and
explore just the depths of our soul and
what we care about and what we take for
and and what hurts and just everything
like just a deep human connection that
that's that's always been something
that's nourished me more than just about
anything and so I think when I found
this work it was it was like coming home
again it's like oh my god I like I've
I've had this with my best friends and
and and lovers in my life but it's but
it still feels relatively rare and even
at those times it's like to get to the
depth even with people that I've want to
with like it sometimes it's just
happened it's like whoa like how did
that happen where we just went had like
how do you recreate that on purpose and
this to me gives me access to that
and and even with people that I just
meet sometimes like we have this
connection after 10 minutes with
somebody that I might have not had with
a friend who I was just sort of being a
everyday kind of friend with four years
you just kind of get to a certain level
and you think you know each other and
then you stop and then it's all just
catching up on details first it's like
you said I want to know what's in your
heart
such a beautiful question what is the
love feel like feels warm feels soft
nourishing safe
supportive
as you're saying these like I'm home I'm
melting myself you're saying these
things yeah love and how it makes you
feel
it feels like somehow like there's this
bond of like I'm somebody's like
reveling in an enjoying like my
existence and and and and like who I
know myself to be and they're helping me
like be more intimately accepting and
loving of even that and that's and and
I'm with them in the same way yeah it's
just this is this beautiful flow
where does the feeling these feelings
where do they live for you I think for
me they act they actually it's it's
everywhere like I mean people
traditionally feel it here and I think I
do too
I just feel it flush throughout my whole
body yeah and and somehow I think I
don't know how I sensed it but just
throughout my whole energetic existence
yeah yeah just there he just leaves like
that it's a great question
I think I was but it was it was it was
numb it was turned off I think I didn't
have access to it as a child okay Leslie
as a child I felt lost and disconnected
like I was I always had this level of
sensitivity like I was tuned into
something else and and the the way that
most people were relating as I was
growing up just felt really harsh and I
just like wanted to hide from it
and I mean I could engage I could you
know enjoy you know mixing it up at
times and that kind of thing but most of
the time it's because I felt the lack of
this part of me being validated and
earned and nourished I think I mostly
just kind of shut down for most of my
childhood the feeling of disconnect what
did that feel like where did you feel it
and it was just a profound hurt like
where did I feel that I'm not exactly
sure I just wanted like the sense I have
is like one of this but just wanted that
like curl up into a ball and hide and
hide in my room like I didn't even want
to engage with my family I just kind of
like no no place felt safe so there was
like a baseline level of anxiety or not
quite terror but it seemed like that
what was causing disconnect
the the I I do really feel that what was
I think it was it was that's the lack of
of people who could tune in to that part
of me of like the richness of who I was
and that and then like my love for that
kind of connection and reflection like
it just people just didn't communicate
that way and my upbringing in my
childhood and my schooling and that kind
of thing so but you knew you needed that
I didn't know I didn't know I just know
yeah I didn't I didn't I didn't have
like it was something incredibly missing
and I didn't know what it was so it felt
amazingly depressing you know and and
depression wasn't a thing when I was
growing up so I maybe that's a good
thing because I probably would have been
drugged into numbness but I just went
into naturally but I probably would have
been good for me to see a therapist it
was the kid but something happened
naturally I do like around 11th or 12th
grade I ran into a group of friends or
just somehow magnetized a group of
friends around me that some of whom
really communicated with this kind of
depth and compassion and care and like
all the sudden I had well some best
friends was like wow like oh my god like
this is this is something like this is
something I never knew was possible
before and I just I came alive and all
of a sudden that part of me like woke up
I was a completely different person and
yeah that like life was all of a sudden
taking on a whole new meaning
to the the feeling of going from to
going to open to these people that are
gravitated towards you that feel you and
get you and their you get them and that
feels like feels like a midwife feels
like her Genisys at 11th or 12th grade
that Wow
it was like an awakening what was
seemingly impossible became possible
yeah that was must have been a big
moment and so then what the first
feelings where did you feel it what was
the emotion when the first happened that
this group and you related
I think I was like awestruck I remember
I remember being in a in a in a basement
at a party at at a friend's house I
became best friends with a woman and a
man and I was and I had separate
conversations with both of them and were
just mind-blowing to me like the one I
think the first one was with the guy and
we just had like a two-hour conversation
at this party where we just tuned in and
and shared our like deepest self with
each other in a way that I didn't know
anybody could do or could bring out in
me or could allow and somehow we just
tuned in and did it for and with each
other and I think we we were both just
awestruck it's like wow like like what
just happened I think this is a whole
something just opened up a door
possibility that I didn't even know was
there with people yeah
and I
I think I felt phenomenal relief
gratitude alive I felt I felt a level of
appreciation and I felt a level of Oh
like I know like I inherently know how
to do this like this is something like
this is like that's like a capacity or a
skill of mine that like I think nobody
has ever seen
what about with a woman afterward same
thing except I I think partly because of
who we were and partly because like it
was my first like awakening and and she
was very attractive I fell in love with
her I mean I fell in love with my friend
- but it was like romantic level or
sexual love right and I fell in love
with her as a person but I also was like
my first kind of like oh and it was
unrequited she was wanting you know just
really looked just as a friend and so
there was a mixture of both aliveness
richness like total disappointment and
depression it's like [ __ ] like the first
time like I finally like get what I
imagine I want in life and I and I don't
get to have it right yeah
so there was a really a mixture of
of excitement and awakening and tragedy
I'm imagining this it's just very very
sweet
miss miss sorry horrible and like he
said the first like all you know but
then the beauty of unlocking that and
Wow and being first inspired by those
two conversations unlocking that in
yourself Wow yeah so the disconnect left
at that point or did it stay there
disconnected myself yes I think a huge
amount of it left you know and there's
always a process which I mean I
experienced for sure of of having to
overcome the accumulation of wounds from
kind of like that lost childhood and
continued to sort of reconnect all the
places that we're dumb down as a result
of that but yeah so that process just
started then really yeah you're trying
to imagine a yeah oh like 13 year old 14
year old 15 year old John that's
somehow in tune with energy and emotion
at a level that other kids your age were
not and what that feeling would be like
to feel like being alone and
disconnected yeah and I can imagine if I
had somebody there to actually tell me
that's what that was and show me and
like uh-huh I always have these
fantasies are like going back and like
reliving again with the consciousness we
have now older brother John comes at you
like how would that be yeah this level
of equanimity towards all this [ __ ]
that goes on just like this fierce
knowingness it's like the neural
architecture is not formed able to
comprehend even that at that age
yeah potentially we don't quite know
exactly but follow-up is this initially
came about by asking if you continue
this this feeling of
of your essence being maximized the
feeling that you know that the impact
that you're making is so important that
you vibe on it so frequently every
single moment is is all of the
disconnect now gone today did it feel
like from that eleventh twelfth grade
moment until now that it's been
non-existent I think a lot of it's gone
yet I'm sure there's more what would it
take to get to them more
[Music]
look we're about to talk to your parents
about how you felt
no I mean my father passed away when I
was about 23 or so and and I was just
starting to really have words for like
my developing consciousness and at the
time he got sick so they were we were we
were starting to have better
conversations but it hadn't gotten to
that point I felt like an appreciative
appreciation from him of like who I was
starting to become but it was so fresh
and new that we never got to that level
of like talking about my past my
childhood that type of thing tried to
have with my mom at one point and she
she really did her best to hear me
but her journey was different her
journey you know was more practical you
know post-world War two and having kids
and making a living and raising her kids
making sure they got to college and that
kind of thing it's like just it wasn't a
journey of exploration of consciousness
for her you know so was I think it was
hard for her to grasp like what I went
through and my struggles I think she had
a sense of it but from a completely
different perspective yeah she still
with us she is this summer she's gonna
be 98 years old I think that's in the
top like 1% of age yeah but that she's
gotten to live a lot Wow yeah I when I
when you were talking about being 23 and
putting words to your feelings and then
aiming to talk to dad about that right
at the time that dad was getting sick I
felt uh
I felt like the son and father were
finally starting to co-mingle yeah yeah
and
although we were very different because
I think just different generations and I
came in I mean considering how I've
lived my life I came in with a very
alternative bent in a and a desire for
growth and consciousness and all that
and he lived a much more traditional
life but I think there was an
appreciation of who each other was
because we were we we were very similar
temperament wise we even looked a little
bit alike so in a sense it was almost
like I was kind of his spiritual
agreement yeah yeah question about the
state that you carry today of this
mission and vision and living a moment
to moment is so you're so passionate
about that are there are there parts of
you that are unfulfilled emotionally the
outside of the success of the vision oh
god yeah what are they I mean probably
my biggest frustration of my life is
that I'm still single just in it's it's
been incomprehensible to me my whole
life I mean I was always really
relational I mean I can remember being
in my 20s thinking yeah if I find the
right partner I'll settle down and get
married where my friends were like no
I'm gonna be a bachelor too at least my
30s and that kind of thing it's like
like I'm ready apparently I wasn't Chris
Here I am but I think I just I don't
know the only explanation I can sort of
make up is
I had a different path and I think that
I loved love so much that if I would
have found the right partner then I'm
not sure if I would have gone on this
path like it would have been enough for
me like I would have found happiness
just in that and I might have forgotten
this whole other aspect of my life
that's just the story I make up in my
head but I do miss that I feel a
profound loss about that still it's
still something that's important to me
and that I want
this
this
this energy coming through you too
bring forth this vision and then the the
missingness
of someone
I always I'm always very curious about
about what this means for the different
people
you made a mean a small inclination
towards is it possible that my purpose
was to focus until now on this so that I
could impact there's still time to still
have someone come and you know and who
would have you become otherwise a
younger age if you found out some if you
have become better would it not yeah
maybe I would have found somebody with
similar dreams and goals on an equal
path and it would have just been that
much easier to do what I'm doing what
what does the what's the weather what is
it the what is a word it were how would
you describe the feeling of the of that
missing ask me the hard questions Alan
feeling of the missing us
it's like
on one hand it's a it's a deep yearning
on the other hand it's it's the loss of
a possibility of a different type or
different quality of life that could
have been
doing it with a partner with a loved one
together the whole journey maybe having
kids family yeah yeah it's a profound
sadness yeah
disappointment
when that when you uncover those move
those layers and come to the sadness and
the profound feeling of loss what then
happens
at times when you say what then happens
like my attention goes to like to
questions or to places like what has
happened and like what's happening right
now right so what's happening right now
is like I feel those feelings but
they're not intense like there's been so
many tears cried over them over the
years that it feels it feels explored
and embraced not necessarily complete or
done but it's just like you know I mean
I've I've I've cried the tears that
needed to be cried about it and it and
so I'm I like go into it and I go okay
but that's what is what about the non
fulfilled part about it
frustration missing wishing and okay so
like all that desire like I can't but I
I haven't I haven't figured out how to
manifest that yet or make that happen
so like all that passion and that desire
I don't want to waste it so it's like
Beth's going into what I love about my
life and what I'm wanting to create and
and and the rest of the people that I
get to interact with and the richness of
that you know I mean I've had and I've
had a lot of beautiful connections in my
life yeah what would it feel like when
it the incompleteness is filled say that
again
that last piece of incompleteness being
filled if it were felt if it were filled
oh my god just extraordinary like like
like the for me the feeling of not just
being in love but really being loved and
and loved for like the whole range of me
we're like don't have to hide a thing I
get to experience everything gold such a
sense for hope yeah you said that yes
Wow and this and this a lot of range
that I don't show often yeah because I'm
just like it's not it's not like a
requirement and but if I'm with somebody
it's like oh like like they get this
slice of reality or the slice of me and
they enjoy it's like okay great
now I can play in that arena you know
but maybe they don't like this so right
I don't need to go there you know or so
like some people just like yeah like be
the comical or the profane or they or
the like woody the John was what some
eyes in every little main politically
incorrect like let's make fun of
everything because like so life doesn't
control us kind of thing like that to me
that's a delightful place I'm imagining
a keyboard and you're like there's only
like three notes or five notes being
played I want to play all 50
all the notes and then the other side is
like the the act the total sacred where
everything is a treasure and needs to be
honored and and treated with beauty and
care and all that and and the weaving
together of both of those in a moment is
a key said an exquisite symphony for me
and so people get that whole level of
reality that's where I just really come
alive and I have people in my life that
like like vibrate there and get that and
get that about me and and themselves too
and that's and it's it's it's it's so
nourishing for me to be with them and to
and to be able to be received and have
that part of me received in general and
and to have them also generate and that
and call that out and it's not my
everyday reality I'm also somewhat
introverted so I like I need to actually
go within and have quiet time and
disconnect time and things like that so
I'm a complicated individual
being with you
I felt this
this feeling that a lot of young people
go through
feeling of being alone with their
feelings
and I felt how that ties to some of the
issues that we have today and that
moment for you for when he first gained
that eleventh twelfth grade group of
peeps yeah
brought a huge sense of smile and relief
to me and then hearing about the way
that you wanted to connect with your
pops and mom on it
and then connect with someone else in
your life that's a partner about it
I'm just so driven
you know by the big vision in schools
and corporations executives the United
Nation and I'm just like feeling so
blessed yeah thanks for thanks for
reminding me of that are seeing that
particular part to like just pointing
out like that like the bigness of dreams
sometimes I just feel like I have a lot
of pipe dream dreams and other times I
just recognize hey it's I have big
visions and it's it's important to dream
big you know like that's just one of
them a lot of big dreams that I don't
share a lot with people cuz they're they
seem to most people a little wild or off
the deep end
I imagine as part of our exploration
into our larger scale live events until
we get to the sports stadiums I imagine
that we do these circlings the way as
part of that it has to have this raw
connection of intimacy yeah
be shown to be totally okay and be
important yeah yeah I'm right there with
you it's spectacular isn't it yeah
okay we have we have so they're a good
circular I am a beginner I know nothing
I know nothing I've heard you say that
before
I gotta keep saying it mm-hmm that's the
way I want to do it so much love for you
my friend thank you yeah
playtime on the woods or on the ocean or
on a boat all right I get a lake
something yeah thank you everyone for
tuning in